bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct celui qui nous accompagne ce soir
vous le reconnaissez c'est Charles de
Courson bonsoir et merci d'être là
l'homme du 8 juin comme certains vous
surnomme à l'Assemblée faire de Lens
dans la bataille des retraites députés
de la Marne depuis 30 ans vous êtes
devenus et on va en parler en quelque
sorte le chouchou le héros de
l'opposition on en parle ensemble dans
la deuxième partie on a du temps pour ça
mais d'abord gros plan ce soir sur la
bataille homérique sur votre proposition
loi Charles de Courson quelle journée au
Palais Bourbon le match retour de la
réforme des retraites fut acharnée en
commission des affaires sociales et à
l'arrivée après quatre heures de débat
électrique l'abrogation c'est non tout
porte à croire qu'il n'y aura pas de
vote sur cette proposition de loi sur
les 64 ans abrogés là le 8 juin prochain
dans l'hémicycle alors le Parlement
sorti de grandi de ce bras de fer grand
débat dans un instant avec nos invités
sur ce plateau avant de retrouver bien
sûr à 20h15 les affranchis pour leur
parti pris et puis Bourbon express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée voilà
pour le programme ce soir vous me suivez
Charles de Courson ça vous regarde c'est
parti
[Musique]
la commission des affaires sociales
théâtre donc de toutes les tensions
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée pas un de ses
membres n'a manqué à l'appel il faut
dire que l'on joue était de taille
labrogation du recul de l'âge de départ
à la retraite c'est l'article premier de
cette fameuse proposition de loi liotte
et c'est le camp présidentiel qui a
réussi à voter sa suppression au terme
vous allez le voir de 4 heures de débat
électrique alors qui a gagné ce soir
article 40 89 1 le Parlement sort-il
grandit de toutes ces stratégies de
procédure et autres manœuvres tactiques
bonsoir Jean-René Cazeneuve et merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes le rapporteur
général du budget vous êtes député
renaissance du Gers ou des battez ce
soir avec Daniel obono bonsoir merci
d'être là député la France insoumise de
Paris bonsoir Alexandre vincentet Merci
à VOUS député les républicains du Rhône
très actifs dans cette commission des
affaires sociales dont vous êtes membre
aujourd'hui bien sûr vous n'avez pas
voté la censure du gouvernement vous
êtes plutôt alliés en tout cas sur les
retraites avec la majorité je n'ose dire
la majorité Charles de Courson le camp
macroniste je sais que vous me reprenez
souvent quand je parle de majorité
présidentielle enfin bonsoir Benjamin
Morel bienvenue à vous vous êtes
constitutionnaliste on a besoin
évidemment de votre expertise dans ce
débat très technique mettre de
conférence en droit public à
l'université Panthéon à SAS Charles de
Courson ce débat il est évidemment fait
pour vous vous y êtes parti prenante
totalement on va commencer par un
exercice compliqué c'est un défi pour
Stéphane blackovski que s'est-il passé
dans cette commission des affaires
sociales qu'est-ce qui a été voté le
tout en deux secondes le chrono de
Blacko c'est parti
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes pour vous regarder du haut de
votre estrade
expliquez-nous
ce soir ou plutôt aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée on a assisté à une bataille
de procédures alors c'est une vraie
bataille on veut vraiment la peau de son
adversaire on est prêt à tout pour le
mettre à terre sauf que bon on utilise
pas d'armes donc uniquement des des
articles de procédure c'est un peu moins
spectaculaire que Game of Thrones moins
sanglant mais c'est quand même un petit
peu tendu alors en fait aujourd'hui on
parle d'un débat sur la retraite mais il
me semble que le débat portait plutôt
sur en fait le rôle de l'Assemblée
nationale dans notre pays qui est un peu
tendance à se réduire certains diront
comme peau de chagrin donc de ce point
de vue Charles de Courson qui était avec
nous ce soir déposer une proposition de
loi pour supprimer le report de l'âge de
la retraite à 64 ans et puisque vous
êtes une bataille de procédure il
faisait référence à un article de la
Constitution le numéro 24 on l'écoute
c'est un article méconnu à tort
puisqu'il ne fait rien de moins que de
définir le rôle du Parlement dans notre
démocratie
je vais même vous en citer la première
phrase
le Parlement vote la loi
c'est simple
[Applaudissements]
oui il fallait-il de rappeler le
Parlement vote la loi mais une fois que
la loi est votée encore faut-il la
respecter ça c'est ce que dit Paul
Christophe qui lui et du groupe horizon
donc il serait faire lui à l'article 40
de la Constitution dont on va beaucoup
parler ce soir et qui interdit de
déposer une proposition de loi si on ne
prévoit pas les moyens de la financer on
l'écoute
déposez une proposition de loi aggravant
les finances publiques à hauteur de plus
de 15 milliards d'euros ne devrait pas
pouvoir être examiné par d'autres
assemblées au regard de notre
Constitution nous le savons très bien
alors attention c'est de la vraie
bataille de procédure bon parce que là
franchement en fait on s'est bien qu'on
dépose souvent des propositions de loi
qui sont pas vraiment financées dans ces
cas on dit oui bah on financera ça en
augmentant les taxes sur le tabac donc
du côté de la nupesse en tout cas que
Clémentine elle dit bah non là il y a
deux poids de mesure on l'écoute
cet article 40 qui vise à retoquer des
propositions loi au motifs qu'elles
engagent de nouvelles dépenses n'aide
ordinaire pas utilisé pour les
propositions de loi et d'ailleurs celle
sur le Bien Vieillir déposer par les
macronistes par le groupe Renaissance
coûtait 8 milliards d'euros et elle n'a
pas été retoquée alors bon du côté de
l'opposition de la nuit parce qu'on a
peu de chance d'apporter cette bataille
dans au moins ne pas la perdre et donc
le but de la manœuvre là c'est de gagner
du temps parce que si en fait on n'a pas
le temps d'examiner l'ensemble de leurs
proposition de loi bien ce serait elle
sera proposée tel quel devant les
mystiques c'est-à-dire avec ce fameux
article 1 qui prévoit de supprimer le
report de l'âge de la retraite donc tous
les moyens sont beaux parfois on a
affaire des artistes donc là je spéciale
dédicace à Arthur de Laporte qui nous a
trouvé un petit point de règlement
franchement apprécié au titre de
l'article 38 de notre règlement la
participation des députés en commission
est libre aujourd'hui on a à peu près
une vingtaine de députés qui sont debout
on peut manifestement pas les asseoir ça
ne remplit pas des conditions de
sécurité des sortes on a la Commission
de la force sociale on doit vérifier
aussi à la question de sécurité au
travail bon alors c'est vraiment pour
les amateurs de batailles de procédures
mais j'en fais partie donc je savoure
rassurez-vous personne n'a été blessé
évidemment pendant la commission qui
était quand même un petit peu agite donc
finalement il y a une majorité donc le
vote l'a emporté donc l'article numéro 1
que vous voulez supprimer la majorité
ben il a été supprimé donc Aurore berger
se justifie en faisant référence à quoi
la procédure c'est une bataille de
procédure
tous les groupes sont représentés en
commission des affaires sociales à
proportion de leur nombre voilà ce qui
se passe donc il n'y a pas de magouille
il y a pas de manœuvre il y a un vol par
contre les manœuvres qui existent ici
c'est des dépôts de dizaines de
centaines voire de milliers de sous
amendements pour espérer qu'il n'y ait
pas de vote à la fin de la journée alors
c'est là que la procédure a un petit peu
facile parce que bon Fadila gadabi qui
était la présidente de la commission
elle a dit on ça commence à suffire
c'est mille amendements on a qu'à ne pas
les examiner d'un coup bon évidemment
mathildeau est un petit peu indigné en
l'écoute
donc nous voyons
voir la présidente et je
[Applaudissements]
vous le fais du droit fondamental des
parlementaires c'est-à-dire le droit
d'amendement qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
on est où là
l'autoritarisme a des limites madame la
Présidente l'autoritarisme a des limites
madame madame madame panot l'obstruction
non plus n'est pas acceptable
voilà comme ça c'est dit donc
effectivement on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'opposition a sans doute
perdu cette bataille de procédure mais
bon après tout on peut se retirer avec
panache on écoute pierre Daredevil
compte tenu de la décision que vous avez
prise de nous empêcher de véritablement
discuter de porter à nouveau atteinte au
droit du Parlement mais on va vous
laisser tranquille on va vous laisser
entre vous puisque c'est comme ça que
vous êtes bien donc voilà on veut pas
déranger
donc je vais vous laisser les battre
évidemment moi j'ai vraiment apprécié
ces quatre heures de débat ce que je
suis très amateur de bataille de
procédure mais après beaucoup de
déluants parlait de démocratie par si
démocratie pas je sais pas si pour les
autres qui sont pas amateur que moi de
bataille de procédure la démocratie a
été respectée vainqueur bien je commence
avec vous Charles de Courson dans quel
état d'esprit vous êtes ce soir
l'article phare de votre proposition de
loi visant à abroger le recul de l'âge à
64 ans a donc été supprimé est-ce que
vous êtes surpris est-ce que vous y
attendiez
tout dépendait du vote des républicains
puisqu'ils ils sont 8 à la commission
des affaires sociales il y en avait
trois qui m'avaient dit qu'il voteraient
pour ma proposition de loi
3 dont on savait dans l'indici est
présent et qu'il votre compte et il y
avait de qui était
un peu hésitants ils ont été remplacés
ces deux-là par des gens qui étaient
contre donc c'était clair ça finirait à
5 3 en fait sur les trois m’avaient dit
qu'il voteraient pour il y en a un qui
s'est abstenu voilà notre collègue Viry
donc voilà le résultat il était écrit
voilà mais
la mère défaitiste
qui continue il continue aussi dans
l'opinion publique et on reverra ça le 8
juin puisque pourquoi toute cette
bataille de procédure pour une raison
très simple c'est que la minorité
potentiel appuyez en commission par la
majorité des représentants des
républicains ne veut absolument pas
qu'on vote parce qu'ils savent que sur
un vote publique le 8 juin le texte de
l'article premier sera adopté voilà et
donc c'est un vote
on vote contre l'article premier en
bétonnant 5 des 8 républicains ce qui a
donné 38 34 et une abstention absolument
38 pour l'amendement de suppression
contre
et ils m'ont demandé c'est avec plaisir
que je vais le faire de rétablir de
déposer un amendement pour rétablir et à
ce moment-là on demandera à madame la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale de
déclarer cet amendement qui se contente
simplement de revenir
initial qu'elle déclare l'article 40 ce
qui est quand même invraisemblable
puisque cet article premier comme
l'article 2 d'ailleurs ont été déclarés
conformes par le Bureau plus exactement
son émanation puis par le président de
la commission des finances donc on va se
retrouver dans une situation
invraisemblable si la président de
l'Assemblée nationale a appelé que
vraiment cela et il paraît que subit
beaucoup de pression puisque
la pression
du gouvernement notamment voilà donc on
va voir si elle a une vraie autonomie
personnelle et moi je vais dire
l'attention que si elle fait cela ça va
créer un précédent redoutable puisque ça
veut dire qu'on pourra toujours bloquer
une proposition loi parce que le
quasi-totalité production de loi ou un
couple donc on pourra toujours dire
voilà on fait ce petit jeu là voilà et
c'est la majorité et c'est la majorité
du moment c'est la majorité du moment
mais attendez la majorité conseils il y
en a pas assez de mérité présidentielle
mais elle passera comme toutes les
majorités ou les minorités et il y aura
d'autres majorités donc moi je dis
attention parce que alors là les droits
du Parlement se replantés mais sur ne
font pourquoi nous avons déposé cela
parce que on ne peut pas tolérer quand
on est démocrate les manœuvres
gouvernementales avec sa minorité
présidentielle pour empêcher le vote
dans
l'Assemblée nationale sur cet article
premier est-ce que on est d'accord ou
pas pour porter de 62 à 64 beaucoup de
choses
genre René Cazeneuve on a l'impression
que voilà vous vous faites tout pour
empêcher ce vote le 8 juin prochain il
vous fait peur ce vote à ce point-là et
à chaque fois on lui dit qu'on va perdre
le vote bon
Charles de Courson et ses amis ont
déposé une notions ils l'ont perdu et ce
matin nous avons également voté et une
fois de plus il a il a perdu donc le
vote nous fait pas peur non respectez la
démocratie
c'est quand même venant de la part de
Charles de Courson qui a longue
expérience c'est quand même assez
incroyable qu'on se permette de remettre
en cause de manière aussi frontale un
fondement de notre Constitution
peut-être 2 minutes sortie 40 alors on a
constitutionnaliste qui va peut-être
nous l'expliquer précisément mais
allez-y je prends des risques il est pas
fait pour embêter les députés il n'est
pas fait pour embêter Charles de Courson
qui ne connaît par cœur donc un
amendement
il est utilisé des milliers de fois
chaque année oui on nous dit bah c'est
incroyable vous l'avez sorti d'où il
sort c'est vous avez entendu démocratie
il vous dit d'ordinaire sur les
propositions de loi à quelques très très
rare exceptions très cet article 40
n'est jamais
utilisé pour les amendements des
milliers de fois chaque année et il est
utilisé depuis la réforme
18 fois il est utilisé à chaque fois
qu'un député et c'est le droit de chacun
nos députés de lever la moitié qui vous
dit le Bien Vieillir proposition de loi
de la majorité 6 milliards d'euros c'est
passé ça c'est un exemple
quand il y a un consensus il y a
personne n'active personne n'active le
personne active non mais personne
n'active à ce moment-là le 89 4 mais
quand quelqu'un active le 89k alors pas
trop le députés non mais c'est le droit
de députés c'est-à-dire de demander la
recevabilité au président de la
commission
des finances
systématiquement
consensus on le met pas de consensus on
l'utilise c'est de comprendre utiliser
cet article au mois de mai
il y a 10 ans par un député du groupe
liotte qui a dit sur la PPL sur les
drapeaux c'est ça crée une charge pour
les collectivités territoriales donc
c'est pas constitutionnel c'est le
groupe qui l'a dit il y a quelques
semaines donc quand même c'est une
proposition de à 15 milliards d'euros
donc c'est vrai que la charge financière
elle est là il s'agit de la réforme ceci
est faux sur les drapeaux
et là il a il a il a posé la question
mais il n'a pas saisi et il a saisi le
président bien sûr
alors on vérifiera sur la question de la
proposition de loi drapeau européen dans
les mairies c'est pas notre sujet ce
soir Alexandre Vincendet Charles de
Courson a parlé d'un remplacement des
membres de la commission des affaires
sociales par d'autres députés ce qu'on a
appelé toute la journée oui mais quand
on vote pas la censure ou quand on la
vote ça crée quand même une différence
politique importante ça vous l'assumer
il y a deux députés LR notamment
heureux je suis heureux que Charles de
Courson qui est visiblement et constant
dans sa carrière politique il faut
peut-être qu'on parlera un peu de
constance dans un instant avec Charles
de Courson en ce moment la constance est
un peu perturbante
a fait un switch avec un de ses
collègues pour venir dans notre
commission des lois je rappellerai
madame panot ne siège pas la commission
des lois madame panot madame panot est
venu à la commission des lois madame
Gruet
sur les retraites
qui étaient annoncés par monsieur de
Courson y compris sur des députés
présents
et ceux qui ont été réellement fait dans
la commission il y a déjà un écart donc
entre la vérité de monsieur de Courson
et la vérité des votes si prenait par
exemple vous disiez moi quoi qu'il
arrive je sais que j'avais trois voix
pour et bien il apparaît que finalement
j'en ai plus que deux puisque un c'est
obtenu donc ça veut bien dire que pour
le coup vos comptes n'étaient pas bon et
qu'il appartient en groupe de choisir
qui viendrater par ailleurs il y avait
madame Gruet si puisque elle est députée
a été remplacé puisqu'elle était absent
et elle avait voté la sensuelle mais
elle l'a dit également aujourd'hui elle
a dit si j'avais étant commission
j'aurais voté pour la suppression de
l'article 1 puisque aujourd'hui il y a
un vrai on va faire tourner la parole
mais vous êtes les républicains ou c'est
que vous étiez divisé sur les retraites
les Français qui nous regardent et qui
vous ont élu ils ont bien du mal à
comprendre ce qui se joue en tant que
républicain on sait qu'au Sénat de
droite de toute façon cette proposition
de loi n'aboutirait pas puisque les
sénateurs ont voté les 64 ans vous
comprenez vous que ce vote n'est pas
lieu tant que vous vous je ne comprends
pas c'est que quand vous défendez
campagne électorale après campagne
électorale une réforme des retraites
pendant les primaires pendant la
présidentielle pendant les législatives
et que vous arrivez en responsabilité à
l'Assemblée nationale et vous faites
l'inverse ça j'ai du mal à le comprendre
ma question vous nous parlez
contradictions et des enchantements des
autres mais vous-même
la réforme des retraites à 65 ans
arrivent ici et combat la réforme des
retraites
quand vous êtes quand vous faites une
campagne électorale que vous annoncez la
couleur et que vous défendez ça depuis
des années vous ne pouvez pas changer
d'avis simplement parce que vous avez
peur de l'opinion alors faire de la
politique
changer d'opinion au gré des sondages
parfois la politique c'est faire ce qui
est nécessaire
vous me l'accordez aussi donner la
possibilité
aux élus de voter dans l'hémicycle ça
aussi c'est de la politique mais il y a
pour vous un vote il y a eu un vote
suppression
de censure qui n'a pas été adopté les
députés se sont prononcés
les membres de votre groupe à ma
connaissance sont divisés
et donc quand vous me critiquez vous
critiquez aussi une partie de vos
propres amis je l'ai déjà fait première
remarque première remarque je ne vous ai
pas interrompu Vincent day ne vous
fâchez pas je ne vous ai pas interrompu
de vous fâchez pas deuxième je ne me
fâche pas du tout
deuxième moi moi j'ai été élu aux
élections législatives pour la 7e fois
et moi je n'étais pas du tout d'accord
avec les 62 65 ans à l'époque de
monsieur le Président de la République
lequel avait promis en 2017 exactement
l'inverse c'est à dire qu'il ne
toucherait pas et 62 ans je ne vous ai
pas coupé enfin on va laisser terminer
Charles de course
et vous savez parfaitement comment je
l'ai expliqué quelles étaient les
mesures qu'on a proposé d'ailleurs à la
première ministre qu'elle a entièrement
écarté qui est d'accélérer le mouvement
spontané puisqu'à les personnes qui
partent à la retraite sont à 63 ans et
demi l'âge effectif et que nous avions
proposé cinq mesures aucune n'a pas
retenu par la première ministre en
projet ce mouvement voilà ce qui nous
différencie allez on va pas refaire le
débat de fond sur les retraites parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un débat de
procédure qui a eu lieu Daniel obono la
France insoumise a donc claqué la porte
de cette commission des affaires
sociales messieurs si je peux me
permettre ces derniers points c'est pas
parce que vous soutenez un candidat un
que vous êtes d'accord sur toutes ces
propositions il y avait pas de candidats
de mon courant politique et donc moi je
soutiens celui qui est le moins éloigné
pour la retraite à 65
vous n'avez pas soutenu madame Pécresse
vous n'hésitez pas membre du parti les
républicains j'ai soutenu la retraite la
réforme des retraites c'est un problème
constance donc vous avez voté pour les
enfin il y a pas de vote à l'Assemblée
sur les positions des uns et des autres
sur le fond la France insoumise a donc
décidé de quitter la salle de la
commission des des affaires sociales
Daniel obono pour vous qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé le droit d'amendement a été
bafoué oui très clairement il y a eu une
décision prise
de matière autoritaire arbitraire parce
que je crois que ça traduit en vérité la
fébrilité du camp macroniste je veux
dire tout ça pour ça pour faire en sorte
que n'arrive pas en hémicycle un article
que les macronistes prétendent de
pouvoir balayer d'un revers de main
parce qu'ils ont suffisamment de vote
mais en fait qu'ils essaient d'empêcher
d'arriver et je pense que ça traduit en
vérité leur faiblesse parce qu'ils
savent qu'au bout de six mois malgré le
passage en force malgré le 49-3 malgré
la répression des mobilisations encore
aujourd'hui les sondages montrent qu'une
large majorité de français et de
françaises sont contre cette réforme
même alors qu'elle est passée une large
majorité de Français de françaises
souhaitent que la mobilisation continue
et ce qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est exactement ce que nous
dénonçons depuis le début rappeler et
les résultats 38 députés pour supprimer
un article et 34 contre ça fait voilà
mais nous nous souhaiterions que ce vote
il puisse avoir lieu aussi le 8 juin
parce que c'est parce que parce que
parce que ce n'est pas la même chose
dans la commission où on va dire que le
cadre est beaucoup plus contrôlable
parce que justement on peut changer les
personnes qui votent tout le monde ne
peut pas voter en commission à part les
commissaires que dans l'hémicycle ou
d'une certaine manière ceux qui auront
piscine ce jour-là ne pourront pas
compter leur voix contre le texte et
donc on voit que il peut y avoir quels
sont les scénarios possibles pour la
suite Benjamin Morel
quel est votre regard de
constitutionnaliste sur ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui au sein de la
commission des affaires sociales est-ce
que le droit parlementaire est-ce que le
droit constitutionnel ont été respectés
mais si vous voulez le droit
constitutionnel comme le droit
parlementaire ce sont des droits
politiques donc évidemment il y a une
lecture qui peut être une lecture
extrêmement rigide des articles mais si
on prend l'article 40 la lecture a
toujours été assez souple en réalité
tout bêtement parce que c'est un article
qui est quand même le vilain canard de
la Constitution en 2008 lorsqu'on a fait
la réforme conditionnelle vous avez deux
anciens présidents la commission des
finances qui ne passe pas pour étant
d'extrêmement grand dépensier qui est à
l'époque Jean Arthur au Sénat et Didier
Migaud à l'Assemblée nationale qui ont
demandé la suppression de cet article
parce que très très clairement c'est un
outil Éric woert qui a peu donc il y a
réellement je dirais de la part des
parlementaires une allergie à un article
qui si on a les droits de production de
fait non seulement restreint les droits
de l'opposition mais restreint les
droits du Parlement donc comment est-ce
qu'on a fait pendant des années on a
considéré que on pouvait avoir une
application souple de l'article 40
encore une fois pour ceux qui nous
regardent l'article 40 l'article 40
c'est un article sur les irrecevabilités
financières toute initiative
parlementaire amendement proposition de
loi qui créerait des charges
supplémentaires et par nature un
constitutionnel mais évidemment on
parlait tout à l'heure des drapeaux y
compris des charges qui seraient minimes
pourraient tout d'un coup et ben être
considéré comme relevant l'article 40 et
donc vous imaginez bien que si on
l'applique dans toute sa rigueur il y a
pas grand chose qui se passe le cours
sont alertes au fond sur les
conséquences de cette nouvelle usage de
l'article 40 vous le rejoignez
exactement c'est à dire que qu'est-ce
qui se passe d'habitude sur les
propositions de loi on considère que
quand sont des propositions de
Guadeloupe d'opposition elles ont peu de
chance d’aboutir donc on ferme les yeux
et on considère que et bien il y a une
fonction tribunal de l'opposition et que
donc elle peut débattre quand ce sont
des propositions loi de la majorité ou
des propositions loi contre je dirais
consensuel c'est ce que disait bien
monsieur le rapporteur général on laisse
également passer le vrai risque c'est
que demain quand vous aurez des
propositions de loi consensuelles venant
même de la majorité qui pourrait faire
avancer le schmilblick sur un certain
nombre de sujets et bien si on applique
l'article 40 comme il a été appliqué ici
elle ne devrait pas passer et donc
infinet le risque c'est que ce soit pas
seulement l'opposition qui soit brimée
dans sa possibilité d'expression mais
que ce soit tous les parlementaires qui
demain et bien soient réellement limité
dans leur pouvoir d'initiative je
rappelle un mot qu'on a l'un des
Parlement les plus faibles du monde
occidental quand vous prenez les études
en sciences politiques c'est pas la
peine de lui en rajouter alors Jean René
Cazeneuve ça peut être presque pour la
suppression de de cet article 40
Benjamin Morel n'y est pas complètement
hostile à l'entendre au point est-ce que
ce serait pas la solution
sur l'article 40 bon simplement je dis
ça on change pas les règles du jeu au
milieu de la partie si vous voulez donc
aujourd'hui on a une constitution
aujourd'hui on a une Constitution il
faut juste l'appliquer et arrêter de me
dire qu'on n'utilise pas l'article 40 on
utilise des milliers de fois Milliat de
fois chaque année et 18 fois depuis la
réforme sur des PPL ou des parties de
PPL mais sur le risque sur mais oui de
cet usage une fois plus c'est pour
protéger nos finances publiques vous
imaginez ce qui peut se passer s'il y a
pas d'article 40
Charles de Gauchon des dizaines de fois
a pris la parole pour pour l'expliquer
vous avez avec la possibilité
vous ouvrez la boîte de Pandore sur des
dépenses colossales c'est hélas
aujourd'hui on peut le discuter mais
c'est la prérogative du gouvernement
c'est le gouvernement qui engage sa
responsabilité sur un budget et qui est
responsable sur ce budget qui peut créer
des charges supplémentaires il y a que
lui qui peut le faire alors justement
actionné dans le cadre où votre texte
reviendrait via un amendement de
restauration de l'abrogation des 64 ans
du rétablissement on verra c'est à la
responsabilité de la présidente de
l'Assemblée il y a autre chose qui s'est
passé sur les sous-amendements quelqu'un
veut en parler pour expliquer la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales il y avait toute une série de
centaines de sous amendements de la
France insoumise de la
loupessements qui ont été déposés par la
nupes sont arrivés après la suppression
de l'article 1 donc après que les
députés se soient exprimés pendant cette
commission pour la suppression de
l'article 1 et donc à partir de ce
moment-là la nupes qui avait déjà fait
de l'obstruction pour ne pas voter
l'article 7 pendant la réforme des
retraites à de nouveaux faits de
l'obstruction mais pour qu'on ne vote
pas une proposition de loi qui du coup
ayant été modifiée par une majorité de
députés et qui ne leur était donc pas
favorable bien du coup n'arrivent pas au
bout du débat donc ce qu'il s'est passé
c'est que la réuni le bureau de la
commission du bureau de la commission et
la présidente de la commission après un
vote du bureau avec un vote avec
moi la commission
je rappelle simplement la note qui est
parfois peut avoir un peu de problèmes
avec les institutions le respect de la
démocratie etc que il y a quand même un
conseil constitutionnel et que le
Conseil constitutionnel dans des
jurisprudences à rappeler que le droit
d'amendement pouvait être encadré quand
celui-ci était utilisé de manière
abusive il y en a eu plusieurs dans les
années 80 avec des dans les années 90
donc si vous estimez que le Conseil
constitutionnel est un organe légitime
dans notre démocratie puisque c'est
d'accord sur la démocratie
toujours vous montrer un sujet sur la
suite sur ce qui vient d'être dit
allons glissé vers l'extrême gauche et
d'avoir exactement la même comportement
jeudi c'est un déb
ardeur vous êtes tout jeune dans cette
maison ah si on commence à dire je
balaye les sous amendements à hauteur de
combien c'est à partir de 50 de 100 de
200 il y a eu des tas de textes où il y
avait 20 30 40 50 sous abonnement déposé
en séance c'est pas un problème vous
voyez donc il faut être pondéré et
raisonnable et pas dire tout en or et
blanc on entend l'avertissement que vous
lancez ce soir sur ce plateau que
va-t-il se passer maintenant que va-t-il
se passer le 8 juin dans l'hémicycle les
opposants à la réforme des retraites
vont-ils se remobiliser ou la page est
finalement tournée décryptage Marco
polonais
colère et détermination les opposants à
la réforme des retraites ne lâche rien
cet après-midi à deux pas de l'assemblée
et à l'appel de la France insoumise près
de 200 personnes se sont rassemblées
pour maintenir la pression sur le
gouvernement
la bataille continue encore plus au
début c'était un combat pour le droit
d'être travailleuses et des travailleurs
à ne pas travailler jusqu'à 64 ans comme
le voulait la majorité de la population
aujourd'hui c'est une bataille pour la
démocratie bataille pour la démocratie
alors que la commission des affaires
sociales a rejeté labrogation des 74 ans
mais le groupe iode va réintroduire sa
mesure phare par un amendement objectif
en débattre à nouveau le 8 juin prochain
dans l'hémicycle un scénario qui
autoriserait la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale a brandir le coup
près de l'irrecevabilité financière au
titre de l'article 40 de la Constitution
résultat le vote pourrait être empêché
il y a le brune pivée se dit prête à
prendre ses responsabilités j'entends
même des gens dire ce serait
antidémocratique d'empêcher le vote on
entend ça
j'ai envie de vous dire je trouve ça
dingue je trouve ça dingue parce que
c'est l'application de la loi et de la
règle et il n'y a rien de plus
démocratique que d'appliquer la loi
tentative de sabotage d'après
l'opposition la nupes le rassemblement
national et le groupe yote n'exclut pas
de déposer une nouvelle motion de
censure pour faire tomber le
gouvernement d'Elizabeth borne la
dernière c'est jouer à neuf fois près
parce qu'il peut faire qu'on dépose une
motion de censure c'est voir comment le
Parlement est humilié c'est aussi la
perspective à mon avis mais j'en
discutera avec mes collègues de faire en
score meilleur que la dernière fois
sentir qu'on a vraiment une possibilité
cette fois-ci de renverser le
gouvernement manœuvre contre manœuvre la
bataille parlementaire pourrait se
poursuivre d'autres groupes politiques
envisagent de reprendre le texte du
groupe yote à l'occasion de leur journée
d'initiative parlementaire
[Musique]
j'ai tout connu en 30 ans voilà et mais
il y a un principe si vous voulez c'est
qu'on est dans une situation totalement
originale puisque il n'y a pas de
majorité c'est ça la vérité les Français
l'ont voulu il y a pas de majorité
absolue et donc le problème c'est est-ce
qu'on peut continuer à avoir une
minorité présidentielle qui se comporte
comme si ils étaient majoritaires c'est
pas possible les textes pas c'est pas
possible
[Musique]
je respecte
le camp présidentiel n'a pas intégré
qu'il n'avait pas la majorité absolue
gardez vos débats de congrès
qui représente la majorité
présidentielle là-dessus finalement le
Parlement est bloqué d'une certaine
façon aujourd'hui et quelque part le
règlement la Constitution le 49 francs
on voit bien que ça ne pourra pas être
éternel l'opinion le supporterait pas ça
vous le sentez quand même les Français
nous ont donné une majorité relative et
donc effectivement on est tenu à voir
des comportements différents de ce que
nous avions et nous avons depuis le
début de ce mandat votez des dizaines de
lois en allant chercher systématiquement
des majorités on n'a pas d'autre choix
et c'est très bien comme ça donc on
discute avec LR on discute avec une
partie de la gauche et nous arrivons à
voir sur la grande très grande majorité
des textes des consensus qui nous
permettent de passer le vote donc nous
agissons et nous agissons très bien
maintenant sur les textes financiers
qu'est-ce que je veux dire ce n'est pas
capable de trouver une majorité mais il
faut aussi quand même que les Français
comprennent que à chaque fois que nous
sommes battus
et que ça les fait se lever applaudir
ricaner c'est à chaque fois l'extrême
gauche et l'extrême droite ont voté
ensemble c'est une condition nécessaire
c'est pas suffisant il faut aussi qui
est l'apport de l'iode quelquefois faut
y arriver de quelques
LRS
très clairement maintenant la majorités
est-ce que c'est pas elle la grande
gagnante de cette crise des retraites je
pense que certains aimeraient beaucoup
et d'ailleurs on voit depuis le début de
ce mandat comment les macronistes font
tout pour désigner le RN comme
l'adversaire idéal parce que c'est un
adversaire en carton effectivement il
n'était pas consignateur de cette
proposition
il n'était pas dans les manifestations
et ça leur va très bien d'ailleurs quand
vous leur offrez sur l'empatho tous les
pires débats possibles moi je crois
qu'on ne gouverne pas contre le peuple
et on ne gouverne pas contre contre le
Parlement et ce n'est pas simplement
Daniel obono qui le dit aujourd'hui nous
sommes la risée au niveau international
y compris des alliés de la macronie ne
comprennent pas comment vous pouvez
penser parler du mode de François Bayer
avoir un tel comportement
et bien après il y aura encore de la
gestation populaire
vous reviendrez Benjamin Morel on a
besoin de votre éclairage de
constitutionnalisme ces techniques mais
c'est extrêmement politique et
démocratique on s'arrête la merci merci
d'être venu débattre sur LCP vous restez
avec moi Charles de Courson dans une
dizaine de minutes elle est partie près
de nos affranchis ce soir le regard de
Carole Barjon sur le recadrage par
Emmanuel Macron d'Élisabeth borne sur le
rassemblement national et une petite
nouvelle dans l'équipe toutes de bleu
vêtue et ultra bronzé c'est Cécilia
gabizon qui va pousser un coup de gueule
sur le retour en grâce et diktats de la
minceur enfin dans Bourbon Express ce
soir les propositions chocs des députés
sur l'immigration pour Mayotte on verra
ça avec Stéphanie Despierres mais
d'abord on va parler un peu de vous
Charles de Courson quelle trajectoire
quand même qui aurait pu imaginer que
vous défendriez vous deviendriez plutôt
l'homme qui fait trembler le
gouvernement vous êtes un peu le vétéran
de l'Assemblée le père la rigueur le
centriste et vous êtes aujourd'hui le
chouchou de la gauche regardez comment
cette trajectoire a été rendue possible
c'est dans l'invitation de Marion Becker
on en parle ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Charles de Courson
c'est parce que vous vivez votre heure
de gloire en quelques mois vous êtes
devenu l'attraction de l'assemblée
en défiant la macronie vous êtes devenu
la coqueluche de l'opposition
c'est pas mon truc libre les libertés et
qui au nom de ça a pris des positions
fortes depuis maintenant plusieurs
années et qui manifestement est très
attaché à la démocratie parlementaire au
point de ne pas accepter les méthodes je
crois que c'est surtout ça qui le fait
réagir aujourd'hui du gouvernement
dans l'hémicycle vous êtes autant
applaudis par la France insoumise que
par le rassemblement national
quelle ironie du sort pour vous le
député aristocrate descendant d'une
famille très engagée politiquement car
Charles de Courson ou plus précisément
Charles Amédée Dubuisson de Courson vous
êtes député de la Marne depuis 1993 30
ans un an et 27 jours très précisément
tour à tour EDF udi non inscrit en 2018
vous avez cofondé le groupe liotte
longtemps surnommé le moine soldat de
l'Assemblée pour votre rigueur vous le
bourreau de travail vous êtes incollable
sur les sujets budgétaires un traitable
sur le règlement dans cette croisade que
vous menez pour les droits du Parlement
vous avez écorné votre image quitte à
vous faire des
ennemisé que chacun aurait droit à son
quart d'heure de célébrité du petit buzz
pour essayer de gagner un peu en
célébrité quitte à trahir des années de
conviction ou pendant des années il a
porté recule de l'âge de départ à la
retraite si on avait écouté le Charles
de Courson de 2013 on serait déjà 65 ans
aujourd'hui et cette image Charles de
cours qu'on vous en jouez et puis alors
ça ce sont mes neveux qui m'ont qui m'a
offert cela voilà parce que ça les a
fait beaucoup rire vous voyez c'est
assez drôle
alors on vous pose la question Charles
de Courson avez-vous l'âme d'un
révolutionnaire
ça vous fait sourire oui ça me fait rire
même vous savez pourquoi vous posez
aussi la question parce que l'un de vos
aïeux Louis Michel Le Peltier de
Saint-Fargeau député sous la Révolution
député noble a voté l'exécution de
Bruxelles alors il y a quand même
quelque chose peut-être d'une âme
révolutionnaire chez vous ou pas il a
voté la mort du roi comme beaucoup il a
été assassiné le lendemain il n'avait
qu'une fille qui était petite et cette
petite fille a été amenée devant
l'Assemblée nationale et elle a été fait
fille de la nation
et
moi je suis très indépendant d'esprit
j'ai toujours appartenu à des groupes
dans lequel on avait la liberté de vote
et il n'est pas encore né celui qui me
dictera ce que je dois faire ça on l'a
bien compris un homme libre attaché
viscéralement aux droits du Parlement je
crois qu'on l'a bien compris dans ce
premier débat la rupture est totale
entre le groupe liotte et le camp
macroniste aujourd'hui nous aurons
toujours été dans une opposition
constructive par exemple on est en train
de discuter la loi de programmation
militaire nous avons dit que nous
voterions pour la loi de programmation
militaire nous avons aidé le
gouvernement sur le texte sur les
énergies renouvelables et on a eu des
discussions on a tenu compte d'une
partie de nos observations donc nous
sommes des gens ouverts et avec Emmanuel
Macron
moi je n'ai aucune relation je n'ai
jamais discuté avec le président de la
République n'a jamais essayé de vous
appeler de vous rencontrer
d'ailleurs publiquement ce que je pense
oui parce que vous avez la denture ah
oui autoritaire brutale sur les
retraites c'est la manière dont il
exerces le pouvoir ou c'est la personne
que vous n'aimez pas non c'est
l'exercice non la personne chacun ses
qualités ses défauts c'est l'exercice la
façon dont il exerce le pouvoir cette
conception verticale je dis parfois même
egeliane c'est cette croyance que parce
que ton la tête de l'État et que l'État
et l'incarnation de la raison dans
l'histoire et que on va pouvoir le faire
piquer mais ça c'est pas une démocratie
moderne aussi moderne c'est d'accepter
les contre-pouvoirs de jouer avec eux de
trouver les bons compromis qui
permettent de vivre ensemble et le
président Macron n'a cessé que
d'affaiblir les corps intermédiaires
il n'a jamais fait partie donc il
connaît pas trop comment ça fonctionne
si vous voulez il a eu pendant son
premier mandat une forte majorité
puisque son seul parti était majoritaire
ils étaient 310 voilà donc ils avaient
la majorité absolue alors là c'est un
peu plus compliqué parce que son parti
disons les 150 sièges et avec les autres
ils sont à peu près 250 quoi grosso modo
c'est pas avec 250 que vous pouvez
imposer votre volonté donc faut discuter
voilà vous alerter vous dites attention
cette crise des retraites va laisser des
traces la démocratie et le Parlement
vont peut-être être abîmés durablement
beaucoup estiment aussi dans cette crise
que ce sont aussi les institutions qui
sont à bout de souffle et que cette
crise le révèle notamment la Cinquième
République vous êtes d'accord avec ça
si vous voulez que c'est vrai que nos
institutions au fond n'ont pas choisi
entre un régime présidentiel et un
régime parlementaire en fait c'est un
régime semi-présidentiel qui est
présidentielle quand le président une
majorité absolue et qui est plutôt par
le mental quand il n'a pas la majorité
absolue donc le problème c'est ce qu'il
faut rester dans cette situation
par deux fois on a eu une période de
cohabitation qui serait plus ou moins
bien passé si vous voulez et là on a une
situation tout à fait originale un
président réélu pas bien d'ailleurs
et sa majorité
présidentielle sortante qui est mis en
minorité il a fait 25% des voix
l'ensemble des candidats au législatif
on fait 25% des 47% qui sont venus voter
donc dans une démocratie équilibrée
comment voulez-vous gouverner et
pourquoi alors pour un changement
d'exercice du pouvoir ou carrément de
République non je crois que il faudrait
par exemple faire une dose de
proportionnelle on peut pas accepter que
pendant des années des courants
significatifs n'est pratiquement aucun
député c'est malsain pour la nationale
n'a pas eu besoin de la proportionnelle
finalement oui mais il a fallu qu'ils
atteignent 25% des voix pour avoir des
députés alors on entendait Eric Coquerel
tout à l'heure les mêmes choses pour les
Verts je ne suis pas vert mais je trouve
qu'il n'est pas normal qu'un courant tel
que les vers doivent
l'existence d'un groupe parlementaire à
des alliances avec d'autres alors que à
la proportionnelle bon bah s'ils font
10%
qu'ils aient un certain nombre de
députés c'est tout à fait normal 30 ans
à l'Assemblée nationale 30 ans dans
votre circonscription de la Marne que
vous aussi venez de fond en comble
toutes les semaines dans tous les sens
vous prenez très peu de vacances comment
vous jugez le regard que les français
portent sur leurs élus de défiance
aujourd'hui et même parfois plein de
violence si vous voulez quand on regarde
les sondages sur la perception de la
classe politique comme on l'appelle par
nos concitoyens c'est terrible puisque
je crois qu'on est à presque 75 % qui
déclare que les parlementaires sont des
menteurs qui sont là pour profiter de
leur situation voilà et qui n'ont rien à
faire des problèmes de la vie concrète
et la vie réelle de nos concitoyens
c'est terrible
parce que si vous poussez cette analyse
ceux qui me disent cela je dis et tu me
mets dans l'eau ah non non toi tu es un
cas par vous voyez c'est le racisme qui
dit j'aime pas les Noirs mais j'ai un
copain noir c'est à peu près la même
chose
alors moi je pense qu'il y a un
[Musique]
changement si vous voulez de
comportement d'avoir une plus grande
stabilité par la proportionnelle pour au
moins qu'on ait des parlementaires qui
soient stable vous savez dans la
segmentature la moitié des députés sont
nouveaux donc et l'espérance de vie d'un
député c'est un mandat et demi
je voudrais revenir un peu sur votre
trajectoire institutionnel à mon avis
qu'il faut faire si on veut sauver la
démocratie on entendait Coquerel qui dit
que vous êtes avant tout un homme libre
fils d'un résistant qui a été maire de
votre village pendant plus de 30 ans
votre grand-père Lionel de Moustier a
été le seul député de droite à voter
contre les pleins pouvoirs à pétains en
19 40 avant d'être arrêté par la Gestapo
puis déporté en Allemagne dans un camp
de concentration où il est mort en 1945
un mois
je vous sens très émue je suis désolé
avant la libération de ce camp c'est
cette histoire de force et de courage
exceptionnelle qui vous a qui vous a
forgé
oui vous savez on est
pour partie le produit d'une tradition
familiale du côté de ma mère et du côté
de mon père mais voyez nous étions 6
enfants nous sommes tous très différents
vous voyez moi j'ai pas réagi de la de
la même façon que que d'autres moi j'ai
certains des membres de ma propre
famille qui comprennent pas que je
puisse être député
c'est un métier de chien quand on est
honnête j'aurais gagné beaucoup plus
d'argent je serai PDG d'une grande boîte
mais c'est pas ce qui m'intéresse vous
voyez alors c'est peut-être aussi cela
mais les gens sont très différents donc
ça influencé mais c'est aussi une
décision personnelle vous savez quand on
l'a proposé de me présenter la première
fois dans mon village comme conseiller
municipal j'ai beaucoup hésité la
plupart d'ailleurs de mes amis m'ont dit
fait surtout pas ça ça n'a aucun intérêt
voyez
je ne regrette pas
ni femme ni maîtresse votre seul amour
c'est la France c'est pas moi qui l'ai
dit c'est vous vous l'assumez cette
phrase oui un point vieux jeu non
peut-être un peu vieux mais vous savez
j'ai jamais trouvé la femme de ma vie
voilà c'est tout simplement mais ça
aurait pu être autrement oui mais c'est
vrai que j'ai un mode de vie pas très
compatible avec une vie de famille
épanouie avec des enfants dont on
s'occupe en tous les cas voilà vous êtes
un élu depuis 30 ans ici apprécié par
vos administrer et c'est rare et il faut
le souligner vous restez avec moi
Charles de Courson c'est l'heure
d'accueillir à présent nos affranchis
pour leur partie prix vous allez voir
carte blanche au féminin pluriel ce soir
elle vous fait réagir on les accueille
tout de suite
Cécilia gabizon toutes de bleu vêtue et
le teint allait Carole Barjon de
l'obséfinia je rappelle vous êtes
directrice du groupe média et px
Magellan bienvenue à vous Carole Barjon
qu'on ne présente plus de lobbs préparé
vos cartes blanches pour Charles de
Courson parce qu'on commence comme
chaque soir par Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée nous
est raconté ce soir par Stéphanie
Despierres bonsoir Stéphanie bonsoir
alors l'histoire du jour c'est celle de
deux députés qui font des propositions
chocs pour Mayotte Laurent marquant
jelly le président du groupe horizon
allié du gouvernement et Estelle
Youssoupha la député l'iode de Mayotte
ont présenté ce matin le rapport sur les
enjeux migratoires et une large partie
de leur travail et consacré à Mayotte le
101e département français situé au large
de l'Afrique leur constat est accablant
il parle d'une île devenue une bombe à
retardement de service public asphyxié
ce sont leurs mots par l'immigration
clandestine venue des Comores d'un
système de santé plongé dans le chaos et
il souligne que l'aide médicale d'État
la fameuse ame n'existe pas à Mayotte
les clandestins qui vivent sur l'île ne
peuvent se faire soigner pas dans par
des médecins classiques mais uniquement
à l'hôpital qui est donc débordé alors
que les républicains veulent supprimer
cette aide médicale d'État que le
gouvernement y réfléchit et bien
l'inverse ces deux députés veulent la
créer à Mayotte aujourd'hui vous avez
plus de la moitié des personnes qui ont
recours à la santé publique à l'hôpital
public à Mayotte qui sont des immigrés
parfois en situation irrégulière la
majorité en situation irrégulière c'est
une charge publique c'est à dire que les
frais ne sont pas pris en charge et que
donc les frais sont prodigués
gratuitement si demain vous instaurez
l'aide médicale d'État vous allez avoir
la possibilité au moins pour l'hôpital
de Mayotte de faire face financièrement
à cela
les deux députés estiment que l'argent
versé par l'État au titre de l'aide
médicale d'État permettrait de dégager
deux fois plus de budget pour l'hôpital
de Mayotte voilà coup de projecteur donc
sur Mayotte avec ce rapport
parlementaire en pleine actualité aussi
depuis fin avril avec les annonces de
Gérald Darmanin oui Myriam parce que le
gouvernement a lancé fin avril
l'opération wambushu c'est une opération
de police très controversée pour
détruire les bidons villes occupés par
les clandestins et souvent minée par la
délinquance objectif aussi expulser une
partie de ces étrangers selon le rapport
parlementaire la population de Lille a
été multipliée par quatre depuis 1985 et
au moins un tiers des habitants font des
étrangers sans papiers et il y a une
particularité à Mayotte les étrangers
qui eux obtiennent une régularisation
ont interdiction de quitter ce
département ils sont donc coincés sur
375 km2 alors les députés veulent mettre
fin à cette exception et ils vont encore
plus loin ils veulent répartir les
migrants notamment les mineurs arrivés à
Mayotte sur le reste du territoire
français donc ailleurs en outre-mer en
métropole aussi dans l'Hexagone
évidemment sur le modèle en fait de ce
que fait par exemple l'Italie pour les
migrants qui arrivent à lampéduza alors
c'est une proposition forte qui va faire
à débat mais Estelle Youssoupha la
député de Mayotte on appelle à la
solidarité nationale et elle assume les
deux objectifs de sa proposition
le premier c'est que effectivement ça ça
nous permettrait à nous un maillot de
voir les migrants partir parce que une
fois qu'ils ont leur permis de séjour
pour l'ensemble du territoire ils
partent dans les deux jours dans
l'Hexagone par statistiques de la
préfecture mais ensuite connaissant la
situation ici dans l'Hexagone à partir
du moment où l'Hexagone recevrait les
migrants à Mayotte je suis convaincu et
certaine qu'il y aurait tout de suite un
décalage un déclic un petit peu plus
important pour protéger nos frontières
parce que pour le moment le problème de
l'immigration clandestine à Mayotte ça
reste notre problème à Mayotte et moi je
pense que c'est important que le reste
du pays prenne sa part dans cette charge
migratoire qui est insupportable pour
notre territoire
alors ces propositions choc
interviennent aussi alors qu'un nouveau
projet de loi immigration est attendu
cet été la gauche s'inquiète déjà de
transfert forcés de population et
dénonce une approche purement
sécuritaire des deux députés alors je
vous rappelle que l'un et de la majorité
l'autre de l'opposition Estelle
Youssoufa la député de Mayotte elle
espère enfin pouvoir être entendu par le
gouvernement dans le cadre de ce futur
projet de loi bon bah on verra quelle
est sa réponse les mineurs Comoriens
voilà dans nos villes de métropole
j'attends j'attends de voir on enchaîne
avec avec vous Carole vous vouliez
revenir sur la polémique Macron borne
après le vrai faux huis clos du Conseil
des ministres recadrage présidentiel de
la première ministre après ces propos
sur la rassemblement national oui cet
épisode a fait réagir comme à chaque
fois qu'on évoque les origines du parti
de Marine Le Pen l'Histoire avec un
grand H notamment l'histoire de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale bon je rappelle
juste les faits dimanche dernier
interrogé par radiologie sur le parti le
pénis la première ministre a déclaré
qu'il défendait une idé
etc il faut aussi comme l'a dit Macron
quand même et bien d'autres avant lui je
tiens à le rappeler comme Manuel Valls
ou Jean-Pierre Chevènement prendre en
considération les préoccupations qui
sont exprimées par les électeurs du
Front national d'insécurité par les
migration c'est ça exactement on peut on
peut le déplorer mais depuis des
décennies tous les sondages qu'on verse
les Français jugent qu'il y a trop
d'étrangers en France le polythologue
Pascal porino qui est expert de la
question le rappellent régulièrement la
volonté de maîtriser les flux
migratoires c'est l'un des ressorts
principaux du vote RN donc c'est pas un
hasard si Macron a remis au menu
parlementaire les textes sur
l'immigration la fraude sociale etc donc
il faut attaquer les problèmes traités
par le RN pour le combattre
expliquez-nous quand même il était pas
forcé de le faire savoir quand même de
façon assez violente dans le dans le
huis clos on sait très bien que le
Conseil des ministres va fuité bien sûr
il fait ça bien sûr non mais je suis
absolument d'accord c'est une
humiliation parfaitement inutile
tous ces ministres faut quand même le
rappeler elle est le chef du
gouvernement du coup au-delà du message
politique qu'il a voulu faire passer à
l'électorat populaire protestataire et à
la droite on s'interroge évidemment sur
les intentions du chef de l'État à
l'égard de sa première ministre est-ce
seulement une manière de rappeler à
Elisabeth borne qu'elle doit elle aussi
se mettre au même temps y compris dans
le traitement à réserver à Marine Le Pen
de lui signifier qu'elle se trompe que
ses analyses politiques sont fausses ou
bien dans ce cas là il fallait lui dire
en tête la tête ou bien est-ce que c'est
une manière une fois de plus de lui
faire comprendre que ces jours sont
vraiment comptés c'est bien possible
l'humilier avant la sortie la question
est de savoir si Emmanuel Macron a les
moyens politiques de remplacer Elisabeth
borne bah ça c'est encore une autre
chronique pour la prochaine fois d'un
tout petit mot Charles de Courson il
vous a choqué ce recadrage
je suis assez proche de ce que votre
collègue vient de déclarer je dirais
rassemblement national est-ce qu'il y a
encore des petits disques sont tous
morts depuis longtemps ça fait 78 ans
alors là 18 ans
de 95 ans 96 ans le problème n'est pas
là c'est de s'attaquer au problème on va
laisser un peu de temps pour la fin pour
vous Cécilia vous vous y revenir je
rappelle donc que vous êtes directrice
éditoriale et non pas directrice du
groupe un média et X Majolan vous
vouliez pousser un coup de gueule
inspiré par une histoire de cuisse à
Cannes tout à fait alors je sais que sur
ce plateau ça peut faire tâche cette
histoire de cuisse mais c'est important
et j'aimerais vous parler du droit à la
cuisse potelée c'est un sujet en fait
majeur la libération des cuisses et des
corps qui m'est venu après la navante
polémique autour des cuisses donc de
Léna situation alors là aussi je
rembobine pour ceux qui auraient raté
l'affaire les NA situation jeune
influenceuse aux millions de fans est
apparu sur le tapis rouge du Festival de
Cannes dans juste encore pas été toute
cuisse à l'air déclenchant un tsunami de
méchanceté moquerie commentaire acide
car au niveau de ses jambes à la place
des traditionnelle poteau turbinés par
des régimes sans fin il y avait des
cuisses avec de la chair alors rien
extravagant peut-être une taille 38
sachant que la moyenne en France des
femmes font plutôt entre du 40 ou du 42
donc Lena s'avance avec ses cuisses sous
la moyenne nationale et récolte une
cuite d'injure tout comme la fille de
Benjamin Biolay elle aussi dénigrée car
fille d'eux et jugé trop voluptueux
alors moi je croyais que c'était fini
tout ça je pensais que le body positif
c'était imposé c'est pas le cas on y a
tous cru et hélas je dirais que non en
une semaine on a mesuré la fragilité de
cette nouvelle visibilité donnée à tous
les types de corps quelques campagnes de
pub avec des femmes qui nous ressemblent
quelques-unes de magazines la famille
Kardashian et leur forme rebondi on a
donc cru à cette libération au fameux
body positif on le dit en anglais parce
que ça sonne mieux et surtout parce que
c'est au States aux États-Unis que ce
livre en cette guerre concept body
positif contre body shaming le cœur le
corps honteux ou moqué mais derrière les
mots clés les achats le politiquement
corrects on constate qu'en réalité peu
de choses ont changé et c'est important
l'idéal de ma soeur et même de maigreur
et de retour le marché du kilo en moins
du galbe de la consommation de
médicaments et de coupe-fa en tout genre
est en boum et aujourd'hui on a 40% des
jeunes filles qui annoncent des
problèmes de santé mentale lié à leur
image c'est à dire que les conséquences
dramatiques de cette obsession de la
minceur sont puissantes alors
l'obsession de la minceur ça date pas
d'hier non alors justement contrairement
à ce qu'on pourrait penser c'est en fait
très ancien c'est presque alors Jean
Vigarello l'historien le grand historien
des corps parle en fait de minceur
transistorique les Grecs déjà préconisés
la taille fine et on pouvait être viré
de Spar pour un bon point car c'était
considéré comme une faiblesse mais ce
qui devrait nous alerter aujourd'hui
dans cette époque de bataille pour
l'égalité homme-femme et pour la
déconstruction des stéréotypes alors
c'est la perception la persistance de
cette aliénation
alors aujourd'hui la seule nouveauté
c'est qu'elle touche également les
hommes on n'a pas forcément de quoi s'en
réjouir et le pire c'est que sur tous
ces sujets nous sommes tous ou presque
auprès alors vous nous dites quoi que ce
soit vive la chair les premiers sensurs
des rondeurs et donc je voudrais faire
un plaidoyer pour les imperfections les
ronds les longs les cours la chair
heureuse comme celle que j'ai connue au
Brésil ou les cuisses robustes sont
valorisées et si l'on veut choisir ses
combats de libération votaient
imperfections allez voter imperfection
vive la chair et vive les cuisses
imparfaites on va s'arrêter sur ça tout
ça merci à vous c'est la fin de ce
savoirgarde restez avec nous soirée
documentaire Jean-Pierre Gratien bien
sûr à demain
[Musique]